big tech continues its mission to
silence dissenting voices one by one
this week liberal journalist naomi wolf
was the latest victim
suspended on twitter for sharing
controversial opinions about the
coronavirus
journalist glenn greenwald called out
the tech giant's free speech crackdown
tweeting quote
there is a virtual industry of
operatives funded by the atlantic
council which in turn
is funded by gulf state despots and u.s
intel agencies and nato governments
whose purpose is to demand the internet
be purged of anyone dissenting
from their orthodoxies joining me now is
pulitzer prize-winning journalist and
author of
security democracy glenn greenwald uh
glenn thank you very much for coming on
you are
very much in demand because you tell it
like it is and i and your experience
speaks for itself but when we deal with
people like
the president of the united states
donald trump being banned from social
media
to naomi wolf who gets bumped and
youtube videos are disappeared go into
the memory hall
i contend that in fact it's not really
even about them
that that is a message to everyone else
that if we can do it to them
and it's convenient to do it to them
because they're they might be irritating
to people
but it's also a message to the average
person that you had better in everything
you do
watch what you're doing because the new
rules mean that you're going to be
canceled
if you say something that is unapproved
of what do you think of that what's your
take
yeah absolutely agree i think that
sometimes this gets cast as an
ideological war against the right and i
don't really think that's quite correct
obviously conservatives do bear the
brunt the united states
of online censorship but i think it's
much more about barring
anybody from questioning the pieties of
the ruling
class elite there are a lot of people on
the left who are anti-establishment who
also get banned naomi wolf is no
conservative
at all and the really interesting thing
to me that i think is worth noting is
that
when donald trump was banned by facebook
and twitter a lot of world leaders
including ones who don't feel very
positive about trump like angela merkel
and emanuel macron and the left-wing
president of
of mexico condemned that banning and
warned that if tech giants work with the
government to ban
whoever they want democracy is imperiled
and i think that's the right message
that
lots of people around the world see
except for journalists in the united
states
you know it's interesting with your
tweet going through
right the establi the global
establishment and having an interest in
this uh
foundation this platform several
platforms that give average people a voi
a voice which of course is irritating
for them and and yet we had uh i think
was nigeria
where twitter had taken off its leaders
a tweet by its leader
and they banned twitter from their
country it's as though twitter
is being treated like a separate
sovereign nation
because of its impact across so many
boards
and governments having to respond to
what is an american company
a publicly held american company but
needing to deal with it
like it's a country uh do you see it
that way because
there's a point where this the only
solution seems to be to make this a a
utility in a way here in america to stop
the nature of this octopus
from developing from enveloping
everything
yeah that's exactly right you know i'm
against censorship in all cases but if
you have a government
that's censoring that's democratically
accountable you can vote those people
out of office you can
influence what it is that they're doing
with tech corporations they have no
democratic accountability at all they
can do whatever they want
and because they're monopolistic
entities they're starting to control and
police our public discourse
and the other aspect that i think is
very alarming is that it's oftentimes
not even these corporations like
facebook and twitter and google that are
doing it
they're doing it at the behest of
governments they're now democratic party
hearings all the time demanding they
censor more
other governments around the world
insisting that dissidents and their
countries be silenced it's really like a
union between state and corporate power
trying to police and control the
internet which was supposed to be this
innovation that liberated us all from
centralized control
right and of course that was the threat
in and of itself and it worked
and it worked so this is uh clearly uh
when we talk about threats to not just
the united states but the world
this is one of them we don't have an
administration now i think it's safe to
say that has the courage to stand up to
it but
but we will soon thank you glenn thanks
for joining me i appreciate it great
stuff